قال مراسل الجزيره ان سفنا
وناقلات وضعت بل وضعت في بياناتها
الالكترونيه التعريفيه عباره تشير الى
وجود حراس مسلحين على متنها قبل عبور مضيق
باب المندب وذلك في مسعا لتقليص فرضيه
استهدافها من طرف انصار الله الحوثيين في
البحر الاحمر ورصد مراسل الجزيره قيام
اكثر من اح ع سفينه وناقله على الاقل عبرت
مضيق الباب باب المندب خلال اليومين
الماضيين باستخدام هذه الجمله ضمن
بياناتها
الملاحيه معنا الان من الحديده غرب اليمن
مراسل الجزيره سمير النمري لنرصد معه اخر
التحديثات واخر التصريحات ايضا الورده من
الحوثيين نعم في الفعل فقد افاد مصدر
عسكري يوم امس عن قيام عدوان امريكي
بريطاني على معسكر الجبانه وهي قوات دفاع
ساحلي موجوده في مدينه في شمال مدينه
الحديده ولكنه قلل من اهميه هذه الضربه
متقا قائلا بان هذه الاستهدافات تمت على
معسكر قد تم استهدافه لعشرات المرات من
قبل التحالف الذي كانت تقوده السعوديه
خلال السنوات الماضيه وان هذه الضربات ما
هي الا ضربات عبثيه هدف
ال هدفها الداخل الامريكي وليس تقليل من
قوات انصار الله الحوثيين هنا كانت هذه
الضربات تاتي بعد يوم واحد من قيام قوات
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين باستهداف سفينه
امريكيه في خليج عدن وقالت هذه المصادر
انها استهدفت هذه السفينه باستهداف مباشر
عن طريق السلاح عن طريق اسلحه خاصه ونوعيه
قد تم ادخالها في الفتره الماضيه بينما
هذه بينما تشهد منطقه البحر الاحمر التوتر
نشاهد هنا في خلفيتي في الساحل الممتد على
طول مدينه الحديده تسير الحياه بشكل طبيعي
وبينما ايضا تسير الحياه ايضا في ميناء
الحديده وميناء الصريف وراس عيسى بشكل
طبيعي تقول قياده انصار الله الحوثيين بان
الملاحه في البحر الاحمر تسير بشكل طبيعي
ما عدا السفن التي تذهب او متجهه الى
الموانئ الاسرائيليه وكذلك السفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه ردا على ما قالت
انها استهدافات الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا لقواتها البحريه في البحر
الاحمر وكذلك قيامها بقصف جوي على عدد من
المعسكرات والمناطق اليمنيه وان هذه
الاستهدافات ما هي الا ردا عليها وانها
حينما تتوقف هذه الاستهداف دا فات فان
قوات انصار الله لن تستهدف الا تلك السفن
المتوجهه الى الى اسرائيل حتى ما قالت انه
رفع العدوان على غزه وفتح الحصار وكذلك
ايضا توفير المساعدات
الانسانيه كانت كان قائد الجماعه عبد
الملك الحوثي قد اشار في خطابه قبل يومين
الى انه ان قواته ستستمر في استهداف كل
السفن المتوجهه الى اسرائيل حتى يتم رفع
الحصار مشددا او منتقدا القياده الامريكيه
بانها
تدعم تدعم اسرائيل بينما تقف او تقوم
بتصنيف حركته كحركه ارهابيه مقللا من تلك
التصنيفات وقال انها لن تعني لهم شيئا
خلال المستقبل شكرا جزيلا لك من الحديده
بغرب اليمن مراسل الجزيره سمير النمري و